wanna know what's heating up in theaters  this weekend we are only talking and  that is it  take him off we go to Johnson and Jamie  Jordan returned to steam up the screen  in the sequel fifty shades darker you  can't stand there gawking yeah another  guy anymore  legendary hit man John wick is back  taking on some of the world's most  deadly killer in John wick chapter 2 Oh  football I am fighting a few different  people I like to fight around Batman  needs the help of new friends to save  Gotham in the Lego Batman touch oh nice  let's go to feast the Joker's well see  what's hot in theaters with this week's  anticipation  [Music]  so what's your weekend tickets going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]  you  [Music]